Hello Freak bitches. What is going
on? Yeah. How about jail cell and he,
when we had the press conference, he,
this is four days before the fight.
We're both word. He's working for, I
think ESPN for the Mayweather stuff.
I'm waiting for. Showtime
comes by. He goes, Yo,
Max Kellerman didn't
take you on $100,000 bet.
He'll win more than went around a more,
right. I went, no. He goes, I'll take it.
I went, jail. You take this bed, you're
going to fucking pay me. He goes,
I swear to God, I will pay,
shakes my hand and goes,
if Mcgregor Mcgregor wins one round or
more, you give me $100,000 he goes, yeah,
he's not going to touch him.
He's like, don't wind around.
Cool man. Shake his hand.
And after the fight, he was
literally like, you just text me, uh,
yesterday morning because,
hey bro, I'll be in la. I
dropped the cash off. I'm like,
you don't have to pay me, man. It's
not that he was dead serious. He,
I'll drop the cash off.
You said no to $100,000 yeah.
He think he would have said no to
you. I do. He would have made you pay.
I do this type of fucking,
nope. I'm telling you this.
This type of dude chill is Marilyn
[inaudible]. Nate fought. Yeah.
Nate fell on hard times jail
without Nate Marquardt market.
Dude's yeah. Sent him a check in the
mail was, I can go through hard times.
Here's some money.
So when he helped my friend,
like he's always had a free pass with
me. Oh, that's nice of you. Yeah.
Very nice of you. It muscle rich. Whoa,
just kidding. Not Rolling in it. Whoa.
That's crew g. What's Gucci? Yes.
Okay.
[inaudible]
okay.